[Applause]
this is odder than i thought it would be
do you ever get over the fact that
basically my expression through the
whole movie is
tom cruise he really is you know
he's coming straight up all those movies
and he looks just the same
it's incredible to think like three
decades at the top
of your game it's phenomenal and this is
april
nothing but i was a kid and i went to
america
and the first movie i saw in america was
like an audience test screening of risky
business
come on i know really i had to fill in
the card i could have wrecked your
career
[Music]
but that was kind of that was the
beginning really risky
isn't it do you remember kind of the
moment when
fame hit and you thought oh actually i
can't arrange to meet a friend outside a
coffee shop anymore i can't you know
your life changed do you remember your
life changing yeah i remember
right after yeah it did right after
risky business it changed a lot and then
top gun
it was very good
he's a top guy
i feel like we shouldn't ask any
questions we'll just sit here and look
at him for a while
now tom cruise you aren't legendary for
the amount of time you spend with your
fans and
the signings and all that time now when
you meet your fans you've got
this huge back catalogue of movies so do
people want you to like do
lines for movies do they do catchphrases
is there any particular categories they
always want to hear
well there's different ones from
different films you know that sometimes
they'll ask or they'll
they actually kind of shouted at me
sometimes you know and it's the one
that's top of the list
there's not like one no basically i was
like do something oh
okay oh yeah all right okay i'm sorry
yeah
okay okay
amuse us with some tattoos
[Music]
yeah you complete me you had me at hello
you completely
oh help me help you
i want the truth oh yes oh do i
feel the need for speed
sometimes you just got to say what the
yeah
business yeah risky
business i know 10.
[Music]